well my ears finally popped so that's
something you're lucky you didn't break
your neck what is it with billionaires
being superheroes so have you picked a
name yet I'm kind of partial to the atom
you married to that your atom suit quite
the technological achievement mr Palmer
I'm impressed
and he is never impressed well thank you
but I can't quite seem to keep it up
yeah I mean the suit yeah I can attest
that everything else works just fine
there's nothing we need to fix in that
area no the sex is great god there's two
of them I know from Felicity that you
have been very helpful with Barry in the
flash suit and I was hoping to get
another set of eyes on mine got a
problem any friend of the arrows is it
for hell yes
aah guys we kind of have a lot going on
already there's a metahuman killer that
can control a whole swarm of bees cool I
mean awful I'm sure Kayla and I will
provide ample support Barry and I will
be happy to sit this one out you wait
why don't you stay here and work on your
suit well Barry and I run to jitters for
some Java sounds like a plan
sure
hey youtubers is Charlie so just
continuing my short daredevil break with
a new flash trailer and oh my god
there's two of them so this is actually
gonna be really fun episode this is
episode 18 the atom crossover I've also
got some updates about the arrow flash
spinoff series they just need to bunk
some of the rumors so the big thing here
is that the atom is having trouble
keeping it up haha everybody laughed
really hard I guess that means that he
and Felicity are still having sex what
he's really talking about is the
repulsor tected he uses or whatever the
propulsion system is they haven't really
explained what the inner workings of the
suit are only that it's made out of
dwarf star alloy the other thing that's
going on here is that Barry Allen is
teasing the Emily Kinney plot like
there's a miniature bees they haven't
specified as to whether or not she's
controlling real bees or if she's
controlling robot bees in the last
trailer video that I posted she said I'm
the queen of this hive it doesn't
necessarily mean that it's going to be
like a hive type episode I'm really
hoping that they align her character
with that villain organization because
they've all but confirmed that that's
going to be where the villains coming
from in season 4 of arrow Stephen Amell
has already said that arrow season 4 is
gonna change the way they do the show I
think that's more from a story
perspective I think it would have just
allowed them to do grander stories like
you would do with convergence for
instance where it like spills over a
bunch of different comic books I think
what we'd really like to see is Gorilla
Grodd do something really crazy and have
it spill over onto arrow to because if
stuff is gonna go from arrow to flash
then stuff needs to go from the flash to
arrow - grodd's not coming till later
this season so we'll find out like
what's going on in that episode because
it'll it'll probably inform what's gonna
happen with Grodd in season 2 speaking
of next season - they confirmed that the
finales of arrow and the flash will lead
up into what's going to be happening in
the spin-off show
but the spin-off show as far as we know
right now is gonna work like agents of
shield and agent Carter worked like the
spin-off show will air whenever arrow
and the flash go on break for the winter
the only other thing that they've really
said about it is that all the online
rumors like the white canary rumor the
rumor that it's gonna be called the atom
are all false as of right now they
haven't picked the title yet and they're
still trying to cast a few characters
they said they know who their villain is
but I think they haven't cast them yet I
think they're still looking for the
to play that I did make a spin-off video
where I list some of the villains that I
hope that they do but they haven't
really given any indication as to where
they're leaning only that they're not
going to be stepping on the toes of the
TNT Titan show or Gotham or any of the
other existing shows on other networks
like Supergirl it sounds like what
happened when they plan the spin-off is
the CW didn't want to pay for like a
full 23 episode season but they knew
they wanted to do a team-up show I know
there's a lot of questions as to why
they're only doing 13 episodes of it
there are a number of reasons for that
you know one it's easier to get actors
look you don't tie them up all season
long it's really hard to sign an actor
to a new show when you force them to
film like 180 days a year so it makes it
easier to get like really high caliber
talent and when you schedule it outside
of the other shows you make it easier
for like the plots of like say flash and
arrow to build up to some epic spin-off
moment right now the titles that I'd
really like to see them pick include
braving the bold Justice Society or all
stars they'll pick something that's
appropriately catchy but just because
they have a good name doesn't mean that
DC is gonna let them use it so it also
has to be a name that Warner Brothers
and DC will approve we do know that the
number of different names that they're
considering changes depending on the
characters that they're able to cast so
it sounds like they're trying to build
towards like like a Justice League or
all-stars type situation but if they
don't get all the characters they want
they might name it something like
braving the bold which is a little more
friendly for smaller team ups it's just
the Brave and the bold comics usually
involved like two characters together
two or three characters and the spin-off
sounds like it's gonna be way more than
that there was a picture of Hawkgirl on
the set of the flash so it played
something to do with the spin-off they
said that she's not going to be in the
flash finale but they were filming the
flash finale and this picture here says
welcome to the set of the flash so they
could have just been filming off to the
side doing something different it sounds
awfully suspicious but I think it's
gonna happen is is that they'll have a
promo ready for the finale of the flash
and arrow so like whenever those
episodes there they'll air a promo for
the spin-off show so don't forget next
week both shows are back the flash
episode 18 and arrow episode 19 Game of
Thrones is also premiering tomorrow so
be sure to catch up I'll actually add a
link to my catch up video in the
description below okay so my next video
is going to be the daredevil episode 3 &
4 video
make it into like three episode so I
might have episode five stuff into that
just because I started introducing some
new characters so be sure to subscribe
to get that if you guys haven't been
watching or you don't have Netflix
please find a way to watch daredevil
because it's amazing in the meantime
while you guys wait for that you can
click here for all my Marvel videos
including some of the daredevil stuff
and you can click here for more of my
flash videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you a little bit hopefully your
marathon is going great